toes
good morning
it's morning for me and my time zone is
the only one that matters
I don't care what time it is for you
it's not my time so it doesn't exist I
haven't done anything but my character
is 99 overall in every attribute and has
every weapon fully upgraded and every
item in the game I wanted to look at the
churches today Vance but usually how
these lawyer hunting streams go people
take over and we talk about all kinds of
stuff are you moving the camera position
in the game what do you mean
what are you talking about
you don't play the game like this
does anyone else feel
in some ways not everywhere but in some
ways it's like they built
the world
of the lands between and I'm talking
from a development standpoint not in the
game developers
it's like they built the lands between
before the shattering and then [__] it
up I wonder what happens if I go in here
I think I'll just be sitting by morgot
there he is
can I get on this
nope
which one is Ronnie's isn't it skinnier
than the rest I think this one is
no it's as big as the the one over there
radon ain't fitting in that chair isn't
radon's like this one
it's definitely a bit fatter
what's the design on these actually
kind of like the herd tree
he does say what's a thy business with
these Thrones
I mean I I'm at the point where the ER
the the Elden ring was shattered like
thousands of years ago in the time that
we're playing the game
God I hate her but she's looking up at
this obviously
I wonder why nikola's Blood was like
creating a body here
yeah the Cocoon was here
yeah the face is right here
they actually went really detailed with
it like nose kind of
the eyes the lips right here and then I
see this is like kind of like hair you
can see the chest right here
down into the body of a cocoon this kind
of looks like a pregnant woman wasn't
there a Talisman that kind of looked
like that we can look
oh
let's look at each version
the description talks about America so
this must be America and then it changes
and starts to grow
could this represent the halog tree like
the growing of the helic tree
you see how it it gets there's more
detail
especially in like growing branches
and then growing leaves
on the sides
so the description said says it is said
that when the age of the Earth tree
began such blessings were personally
bestowed upon their recipients by Queen
America herself so I think this is
talking about the herb tree not the
haloc tree for sure doesn't look like
there's a talisman
oh sleep torch
okay
Candlestick torch that burns with a
light purple flame the carvings to pick
Saint Trina but in adult form
somewhat unnervingly
okay
look there's even [__] Rune carvings
right here look at that
yeah do you see this as a third eye
because there's clearly an eye over the
middle of the forehead
sorry now I'm looking more closely
not really seeing anything on the
forehead obviously
go look at the Statue of mikola and
Melania and you will see mikola
this is supposed to be Michelob right
and this is Melania
yeah there is another statue
over over here actually
even here
so Queen America
Nikola Melania
maybe maybe uh metal will turn this into
a video I have no idea
you know what to set up late in
curiosity oops
now would you not all just freak the
[__] out
if the statue did something
I'd [__] myself
go to the other one for good measure
we should you're right
I see what you're saying
does this look like something that what
is this [__] thing
a table
missing
pain
dude I just had a crazy idea
wake up
damn she literally doesn't sleep
do you think that the person on the tree
is Saint Trina we don't have any clue
what she looks like other than on the
torch and I think they look similar I
think they look similar too I think
they're the two most similar things that
we've seen
the the way they hide the eyes
is very similar she didn't want to sit
down
[Music]
so she's completely immune to sleep
what about the saint Trina's sword
oh it's right here
with that effector right there
why is she affected by this but not from
the torch
or maybe you have to physically hit her
thank you
it only happened once
wow
where have I seen this
also are these crimson talismans
[Music]
right here
it's the Imperial lotus flower let me
look that up real quick
very similar
but you know
not like enough to say yeah definitively
that's what it is
[Music]
the Dara not
uh very similar as well but not white
it's definitely a knot of some kind like
what are these meant to mean
yeah
instantly demonetized uh
[Music]
I'm looking at the pattern here
yo what a detail
someone just pointed out in chat
her hair goes all up into her wings has
anyone noticed that before
look at that her
holds the butterflies together I didn't
I have never noticed that before look at
that
the muck
true Lord
we have not talked about the church at
all
she sees strength as the mark of a true
Lord strength is the symbol of the Dara
night on her armor
I mean okay think of this who else holds
that Morality In the game
yep Godfrey
does she have a relationship with
Godfrey at all
or horalu yeah
but I can't think of anybody else what
the [__] is that
there's just a black Cube under here
looked under here before chat and that
box was not there
it's just to hold assets for later
why now though
um Godfrey Godfrey Godfrey how can we
get there
I have to go up here first I'm gonna
break this cutscene as well Chad
are you
here's a perspective
see it's already burning
what the [__]
oh a tree you shall burn
burn for the sake of the new Lord there
it goes
it puts the fire over there because of
the angle that they give you in the game
not burning anymore
goodbye
damn
this right here
is like I'm playing a different game
like I'm playing a top-down MOBA like
this
this is kind of cool
someone is complaining that the
tarnished is maidenless
but who are around the maidens to all
the other tarnished around
only vike had one
where where do we see a maiden a dead
mate another dead Maiden it's this one
Church of inhibition
um right here
dead
are her eyes dead
they're just like greened and fogged out
and then she's covered in blood
toes
we'd have to start a new game for me to
go over there so never mind I don't want
to do that
sure is the same dress as the tarnished
either eater maybe she is one
oh there is one at the four belfries
well I could go through the door
let me in no it's not gonna let me in
okay hold on this is gonna be scuffed
ah please be here okay she's here
see her eyes are different
dude this is creepy as [__] oh my God
[__]
you are looking at dead people
are they dead
hmm
all right well that was a waste of that
I mean he's clearly a different person
like we knew that uh her eyes just
seemed very different
they seem like almost snake-like
who who's another snake
uh we could look at Raya raya's eyes
Okay Raya
ooh
not snake-like
not snake-like because she's not a snake
in this form
I think tanet's eyes are kind of either
cat or snake-like
yeah they're they're a multi-colored as
well
what's that called again
heterocromia
got it
uh that's not finger made in clothes is
it
uh this official
officials Attire grummy Blue robe worn
by
madustrial officials to carry out their
Grim tests surveillance execution
gruesome rituals the darkest duties
Drive the wheels of mankind
so this one carries out very dark tasks
how far will you go for me
oh
bye
oh Anastasia let's go look at that
you do lore in The Crucible nights
no
uh that's finger made in a tire now was
it wasn't it in the lore that you guys
told me that uh
she's impersonating a finger midden
that's the word I was looking for
yeah she's trying to lure her victims
she's got like burn marks
you guys noticed that like of her
complexion that kind of looks like her
face is burned
a little bit
butcher knife description
butchering knife huge carving knife made
to cleanly butcher the human body
signature weapon of ogres Anastasia
known to have eaten countless tarnished
while disguised as a fingermen
eleanora in the second Church where's
the second Church
[Music]
foreign
now I don't have any of my Graces
unlocked
can't go to the round table yet
I don't know why she didn't give it to
me in the first place though because I
did talk to Melina at the beginning of
the Stream
she just didn't give me taurine if you
skip or dialogue quickly it seems like
she freaks out and doesn't give you the
ring have you heard ASA but you I can
play turning Rue to 80 if you need to
use this use it to Traverse great
distances it will summon torrent treat
him with respect
just hand out here you go
not received
what the [__]
wow no torrent for me no torrent yeah
maybe the mod broke the game let me see
if I can fix there it is spectral Steed
whistle give
got it okay excellent
let's find out
hello
no
we can read her uh description
I have her pull blade sword forged in
the land of reeds chosen weapon of
eleanora violet bloody
finger
her Mastery of the sword was such that
her Onslaught was likened to a whirlwind
but now her Legacy is stained by a
cursed blood
I had one random thought
is I
want to know whose grave this is
we got our boy here yeah you can stay
there
I want to know whose grave that is
there should be an engraving somewhere
along the middle of the highway of the
four ringed
Fair Missoula Elden ring
I I just don't I don't know where a look
let's do this
like is it on the wall
looks like the herd tree
oh we're not even near the dectus
uh so you mean down here
not up here
isn't this
the same design that malekit like the
middle of maliket's Boss room it's like
this flower right here right
I don't think it's the same flower
move
uh not the same no
okay
that's the Imperial seal Japan I
mentioned earlier
I don't think we can go with any real
world stuff but that is cool
to see the comparisons there
it looks like the crucifix that America
is trapped on up here
the top yeah
this is time of The Crucible then who
would this be
with three shadows
Ashen remains in which spirits that
dwell Spirits spirits of wolves Chase
from their pack
they later encounter a nameless
tarnished
who welcomed them as hunting companions
the wolf Spirits overwhelm enemies with
their agility aiding the Summoner in
combat
Ronnie gives you these wolves by the way
wow I just had a wicked thought
what if it's all
a vicious cycle
that Ronnie wants to keep going
with
until you get her ending
Maybe
like what if the nameless tarnished is
is us every time
and Ronnie knows that because I've
always had this theory of like there's
many many different dimensions
that I think is shown to us when we
fight the Eldon beast and you see all of
those glowing tree trunks throughout the
entire thing
when you get Ronnie's ending she says
the world is going through a thousand
year Journey
a journey into the past
does she say the past
what if nikola's great Rune has to do
with time
and that's why everything seems so
[__] up
like time would make sense to his
eternal youth
that's got to be what the DLC is man
that has to be it
yeah like I I have been trying to figure
out like the time frame of this game
like I think it's all like combined into
one and everything's all [__] up now
you know destined deaths taken out of
the the Eldon ring so that makes a lot
of sense as to like why death is so uh
what is what does Melina say
indiscriminate
let's just go listen to her again before
we were messing around with the cut
scene
dude that's indiscriminate this is I've
said this before that is the most
important line in this game
the world is in dire need of repair like
everything does not feel correct it
doesn't like it's just all [__] up it
needs to be patched together
you know America pulled death so her
children could stop dying maybe truly
die and then maybe mikola took out the
great room that has to deal with time
for his own benefit with helping him
with his eternal youth struggle and
melania's Scarlet rot I wanted to ask
this earlier everyone get your thinking
caps on
these statues were clearly made in
America's likeness right
in all these churches spread over the
lands between the radagon or queen
America
but they don't know where she is so how
are they making
these likenesses of her where she's like
literally strung up by the Eldon ring
is that how everyone knows her as is
this like this figure being held by the
ring
this I feel like this ties into the time
frame thing are these churches in the
future
but how do they know she's strung up
like this because the statues of America
don't show her in this likeness you can
think of uh literally anywhere
up here
like she's not hanging here
her arms are too low I would say right I
know they're cut off but I think the
hair is another element of time the one
this one is with one braid and when
she's strung up she has two braids
right this is just one braid right yep
going to one side of her head let's go
to like I don't know the third church
over here
yeah she's got two braids here
so clearly
further along
are the little summoning statues also
America
let me look at that actually I haven't
looked at those very closely
do these depict America or these guys
foreign
no he's just doing his t-pose
what if the artist put random things in
random places and don't care about the
lore
uh that would be sad
t
First Church America
double braided up on a Tuesday
let me go look at radagon again
God
hey be nice honey Joy
relax
does radagon have two breeds
uh
uh he has one and then just like super
long hair
is it possible that the inconsistencies
are plot holes story mistakes that were
not caught
it's just really hard to understand
and we can be frustrated to be like they
didn't finish the story you know because
it's hard to understand but I just don't
think they've told us the full story yet
they do work hard on the story but I
remember the item from bloodborne that
people slaved over to find his purpose
eventually they said it has none and it
was the Chalice dungeon reward thingy it
doesn't you know that doesn't mean it
was a plot hole just people
wanted it to mean something and it just
didn't
all right
I'm done
thanks for being here I forgot uh it's a
lot of brain power and I'm literally
exhausted right now because of uh big
brain day you know have a great rest of
your day
[Music]
foreign